he is the man of the hour in
Jacksonville and as you know Chris
Brockman a couple weeks ago in our and
my second down I said I was all in on
this guy you did after his first career
start but Washington State fans will say
that they were all in on this guy way
before any of us were he is the 4th
recipient of the Snickers chain which
rewards the NFL's hungriest player each
week he is the quarterback of the
Jacksonville Jaguars Gardner Minshew how
are you Gardner rich I'm good man glad
to be on the show appreciate you have I
am thrilled to have you I mean it is
just the energy that I just get from the
television watching you Gardner I feel
that where in the world do you get it
from yourself oh man I think you get it
from the guys around you you know I
think you get it because you're doing
everything to make sure that they can
win and you want them to be successful
you know I think that's kind of a drives
me now I know that you're trying to be a
team player in a way that there is no
eye on Gardner but but I did see your
dad in the stands kind of think you
might get it from him Gardner am I
correct on that front
he might even get a little more fired up
than I do during games yeah he's lucky
to have that for sure yeah I know I mean
it was he always that way when you were
growing up youth sports the whole
business that's right man he's my first
coach been my coach for as long as I can
remember and he always made sure you
know what if you're not first you're
last you either getting better you
getting worse you always push me to do
great things
well let's talk about your journey a
little bit here did you get any
scholarship offers coming out of high
school where'd you get scholarship
offers Gardner Minshew I didn't have any
d1 offers by the end of my senior year
here I had a few early and they kind of
dropped just with certain circumstances
so from there I've decided to walk on
and Troy because that was a bad bad John
that was my best opportunity and what
happened walk me through it yeah I was
at Roy first semester wasn't the right
fit um decided to go back to junior
college in Mississippi and yeah I didn't
realize it at the time but that was one
of the best decisions I
made went to junior college one master
championship and had as much fun and
that year football as I haven't any
that's Northwest Mississippi Community
College correct yes sir so via
Mississippi
no I'm sorry I'm sorry it's the
Northwest Mississippi Community College
right there I missed the video okay I
forgot I I don't mean to disrespect and
then you went to then you went to East
Carolina after that that's right yes sir
I was there for two years I was kind of
handed out played song played good times
played bad at times didn't win many
games and then at the end of that I had
the opportunity to graduate transfer and
man I'm super blessed so lucky whatever
you want to call it to have Coach leach
hit me up and offered me a spot on his
team and now it started make the most of
that opportunity too well now a gardener
he told me we had him on a couple
Fridays ago that the phone conversation
was a simple one because you were
getting set to go to Alabama and he told
us that it was a very simple proposition
he gave you do you remember what he said
to you on that phone call yeah you said
you want to go to the bench at Alabama
or do you want to come here and lead the
country in passing he seems like you
guys would be kindred spirits is that a
correct story would that be a correct
assumption right there oh absolutely
I can't say enough how much he's done
for me and how much fun we had last year
he's a you know person I'll be close to
forever okay so now we're along these
steps Gardner Minshew did you take out a
hammer and try and break your throwing
hand because you wanted a medical
redshirt what point did that happen
yeah that was my first year at ECU so
initially in the beginning of the year I
was supposed to redshirt and then I
couldn't played a little bit I was gonna
end up playing like a half a football
and lose the whole year of eligibility
and I just didn't add up for me
so at that point that looks like bone
lee option so i tried to break my hand
with a hammer and that didn't work
luckily i'm home but i ended up playing
some of the rest a year got some good
experience and learned that i can't
really break my own him
life lessons come at you fast sometimes
we refer places you don't expect it is
it true that you lubricated before
trying to hammer your hand off is that
true that's right obviously not enough
but uh I did what I thought was best and
that was Jack Daniels JD so any specific
and any specific I guess proof of Jack
Daniels are just the straight-up version
man in black just black let's say okay
and then did you I mean like seriously
big old three whacks at the hand how
many times did you try and break your
hand with a hammer
I think I hit it like eight or nine
times but another man like you just
don't realize like you know you think
you could do it but when you're there in
the situation how hard it is to make
yourself hit you hit your own hand right
that's yeah okay that's that's should
have been a red flag like hey my body's
telling me I should do this should have
been a red flag that's one way to put it
and did you were you asked about this by
Leach and you covered it up by saying
something else is that a true story - no
sir it was Carolina okay I just like I
had a I kinda had a swollen hand for a
little bit okay I got asked a couple
times just said I'd closing the door or
something but uh yeah there's a little
sore for a few weeks
Gardner Minshew here on the Rich Eisen
show so another thing to as your legends
is growing sir I'm doing NFL gameday
morning the other day you probably
weren't watching because you were
getting set to take on I believe it was
the Texans that day and the report came
in from the locker room in Houston that
you were stretching in just a jockstrap
before the game and my question is can
you confirm that actually happen I don't
know about that specific incident but I
have been known to stretch and just kind
of roam in the locker room and jockstrap
only from time
but yeah I can't confirm or deny that
specificity
okay very good are you aware that that
might be considered from some as sharing
a little too much Gardner Minshew
you know what if you can't share that in
the locker room with all your brothers
there then I don't know it works you
know it worked in our Washington State
locker room so we're gonna write down
our Jaguars locker room may not be for
everybody but you know what if anything
is making this closer okay when you say
us you're talking about you and your
teammates okay I just want to understand
what you're what you're referring to
right there and the reason why you do it
is just because what is it just you can
really stretch I mean again I'm a 50
year old man who's doing needs to
probably stretch a little bit more so in
a way I might be picking up a tip here
or two Gardner yeah not never it's not
like a thought out saying it's typically
like at just some point while getting
dressed
you know I'll decide to stretch or
something like that and you know
sometimes it just happens to be where
I'm at the jockstrap pays and that's a
that's what you get well Leonard
fournette says he's nicknamed you're the
drops the jockstrap King that's a true
story too that's what he says man and
comes from Hamlet that's quite the title
so okay what was it like in the huddle
Gardner meant you a few minutes left
with the Jaguars quarterback here what
was it like in the huddle with your
offensive linemen after fournette
rumbled 81 yards but did not score
meaning the big hosses had a run down
the field in Denver in the mile-high air
and huddle up and try and do it again
what was that like yeah you know they
were all kind of running behind the
plate to like celebrating a little bit
like and then they realized oh crap
we've got another play so you know we
try to get him get ever get everybody
together let him calm down a little bit
but you know there's no joke playing up
there I bet I was my next question for
you is I know you obviously grown up a
football fan in the state of Mississippi
Mile High is a is a classic spot there's
been some classic games played there
what in the world was it like for you to
suit up as a starting quarterback
in the NFL win a game there what in the
world is that like for you oh it's so
cool you know let's not try to you know
get to the stadium a little bit early to
get you know kind of a fan boy stuff out
just look around check it out see what
it's all about and then so by the time
game comes I can just you know worry
about doing my job but there's no doubt
it's so cool
Geno's being able to do what I'm doing
right now I couldn't be more grateful
super blessed I was about to ask you I
mean what is this whole experience like
been for you obviously you've got a lot
more games to go potentially since foals
looks to be quite banged up what in the
world is how have you kept your head
about yourself Gardiner oh yeah I mean
you should try to take a week-by-week
you know more than anything like
everything people get caught up and all
the noise and everything that's going on
so then all I want to do I just want to
win a game when one game a week and
that's that's all you really can do
because if you start focusing on her
stuff you're gonna lose it all how much
has foals been there for you he's
awesome I mean he's one of the best best
people I've been around in this game
itself was got a true leader and he's
helped me just keep you know what is
this last game just saying keep on even
when things I look good trust yourself
he instilled a lot of confidence in me
and the rest of the team and I couldn't
be more grateful Robin do you have an
example like where he pulled you aside
or film room during the game at any
point over the last three weeks you got
a good example of what Foles is meant
for your development so far Gardner yeah
I mean I'd say you just look back this
last game you know we're down 17 to 3 in
the first half and he's just hey it's
okay
likes take home we're good you're gonna
do what you do you're gonna make it up
place and we're gonna go win this game
and just given given that confidence to
me is huge you know keep them you know
kind of the steady hand on everything
okay a couple more minutes left with you
before I let you go off into your day
here and you got a big game obviously
coming up in Carolina against the
Panthers both teams two and two when you
when it all comes down to it kid up
growing up in Mississippi who was your
guy I can pretty much guess but that
you're your idol growing up in the state
of Mississippi was who Gardner Minshew
yeah
we're number nine for the longest time
for Steve McNair you know Mississippi
boy I was Titan saying because of him
coming up another time probably I should
be sand but with the team I play for now
but that salad that was my guy earring
there from Alcorn State so because I was
gonna go Favre you know obviously the
old gunslinger from Mississippi but
Steve McNair was your guy huh
that's right that's right your are you
just saying that to butter up the Titans
fans if you're gonna go try and beat him
Gardner so you're saying huh no no
chance no chance I do love farm now he's
uh I've got I've got to meet him couple
times and that's that's awesome
but man yes steaming there I don't know
what it is but he was my god yeah I mean
in your first career win is against the
Titans that's pretty cool in that regard
I for sure that's my fame and who have
you heard from with your newfound fame
here that it was pretty cool whether
it's text somebody reached out to you
who is that person so far for yeah man
it's kind of been cool to seeing some of
the older qvs reach out you know from
troy aikman who called the game of the
night to Kurt Warner has been texting me
talking to Martin Brunell talked to
Peyton Manning for the game seeing all
these guys and just really feeling kind
of a brotherhood that you know that it
is and then SL that's been so cool the
guys that you looked up for too for so
long you know reaching out and trying to
help man it's unreal and then last one
for you Gardner before your first start
the one in Houston a photograph went
totally viral on on Twitter Instagram
etc of you coming out of a plane
looking like you were the quarterback of
the Jacksonville Jaguars but it wasn't
you coming out of the plane that week in
Houston where where was this photograph
that everybody I guess in a way was
first introduced to your style prior to
your first career start
Gardner yeah that was that was out for
the bowl game you know cowboy and my
tubes temp suit that was uh that was all
time outfit I don't know if I'll ever be
able to have an occasion to be able to
wear that again okay but I was
I mean where did you where does one get
a let me write this down Coug pimp suit
where does one get one of those we
actually had a fan and I watched it he
sent it in and said I was the only
person that could pull it off so I had
to do it I could they make those in t LM
sure Gardner they have to i'm sure if
somebody wants to send one end I'll
think about it on the road I'll tell you
what Gardner if it still still works
here I don't know week nine I'll be
calling the Jaguars Texans game in
London if you show up in London dressed
like that it would absolutely the paps
as they say over in London they would go
crazy over that that's where you bust
out the teal version yeah tell Maroney
I'm Coughlin I gave you that idea yeah
is it one last thing to is it true that
your grandfather was going to name you
Beowulf was that true story yeah that's
what he wanted Tarzan was also in the
mix for a little bit but luckily they
didn't my parents didn't love hey thanks
for the time man it's been an absolute
pleasure watching you play football the
last few weeks good luck to you and I
hope you get to play as long as you want
okay I appreciate
right back at you that's Gardner Mints
you at Gardner Minshew 5 on Twitter
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app